zwei schutzwesten und ein visier die
spezialausrüstung muss sein vor die
minenräumer alexander und nicolai mich
mit aufs minenfeld nehmen ist ein
kräftiger eisiger wind das piepsen des
suchgerät kaum zu hören
jedes mal könnte es eine mine sein sie
machen einen gefährlichen und wichtigen
job die minenräumer in der ost ukraine 1
1 kilometer ist die alte frontlinie von
diesem minenfeld hier entfernt die
minenräumer müssen jetzt die spuren des
krieges hier beseitigen jede gelbe
markierung hier bedeutet dass dort mal
eine mine war panzerminen landminen
schaffe blindgänger auf diesem feld
liegt einiges rum was menschen verletzen
oder töten könnte wir machen die welt
besser es ist mein land
wenn ich es sauberer und sicherer machen
kann bedeutet mir das sehr
die ukrainische armee hatte die mine zu
beginn des krieges ausgelegt um die
stadt mario pole zu verteidigen
nun sind hier zweieinhalb hektar
ackerfläche minen verseucht und das ist
nur ein ganz kleiner teil der über 400
km langen frontlinien ich denke nicht
nur an meine zukünftigen kinder sondern
auch an andere leute und ältere menschen
und die bewohner die die böden hier
wieder für die landwirtschaft nutzen
wollen oder einfach spazieren leben
wir sind unterwegs an der front und
treffen menschen die gezeichnet sind vom
krieg alexej gekämpft für die
ukrainische armee einen lungenflügel hat
er dabei verloren
jetzt studiert der politik und hat eine
pizza und kaffeekette gegründet die vor
allem ex soldaten und flüchtlinge
anstellt von den kommenden
friedensverhandlungen
nichts
ich habe im krieg viele freunde verloren
gebiete verloren die ich nie wieder
gehen kann
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass in
zukunft leute durch meine stadt mein
land laufen die auf mich geschossen in
meine freunde getötet haben
bei veteran opitz arbeitet auch juliana
als kellnerin
sie musste flüchten vor den separatisten
aus donetsk mario pohl
der ukrainische präsident lenzen hat bei
vielen ukrainern durch seine politik
hoffnung geweckt auf ein ende des
krieges
doch uljana hat angst ich kannte einige
leute die im krieg gestorben sind und
ich befürchte dass ihr tod vergeblich
war
sie haben gekämpft für unsere gebiete
und jetzt werden sie einfach hergegeben
nach dem motto wir wollen frieden ihr
nehmt das land aber ich glaube es wird
keinen frieden geben
wasilewski also macht ist einfach dumm
frieden aber zu welchem preis diese
frage stellen sich hier viele und an der
front wird währenddessen weiter
beobachtet und geschossen